George Clooney is looking back at the
past and the stars who turned down
Ocean's 11. some very famous people told
us
right
yeah we went to their homes
and sat with them Mark Wahlberg's one of
them he said it right that's right yeah
yeah well there were others oh they
regretted now yeah oh I regret it
I regret doing Batman you know
seven million
yeah George you told us the same thing
many times before I just hope they don't
remember Batman I understand that Julia
has you saved in her phone as Batman
yeah that's gonna change that Batman
suit is pretty tight well thank God they
put the muscles on
kitchen director Stephen Soderberg
reunited for an Ocean's 11 panel at
the team Festival so let's break down
what happened with the cat
Clooney and Mark Wahlberg shot The
Perfect Storm together the year before
oceans Mark turned it down to do Planet
of the Apes Johnny went on to star in
the Pirates of the Caribbean franchise
Captain Jack Sparrow both were
reportedly offered to play Matt Damon's
role this guy's
guys he is
but it all worked out the first three
oceans movies banked more than one
billion at the box office and it was the
start of George and Brad's Bromance I
steal hearts
[Laughter]
Steven went on to direct Magic Mike but
could he bring Danny ocean back to the
big screen I'm thinking about tomorrow I
got you like you know he's gonna do let
me think something new a stripper movie
or something you could mix
oceans Mike magic Danny oh Danny gets
his Groove that's right yeah
[Music]